so let me ask you something here do you
think it's right that a woman could
leave a relationship because of a man's
financial situation
when she's got a kid with the person
me
any one of your ladies i mean no i think
it's selfish i think that's absolutely
selfish if you if you leave a man based
on his financial situation when you have
a kid
because when you have a kid it's not
about you anymore it's about your kid so
if you're mad he's not making enough
money and you're just gonna leave that's
selfish because you can get a better
paying job also you can step up and do
more yeah i believe that in that
situation it's you're meant to be a team
you know a team so if someone's going
you know if that's happened to them you
think you know what i mean step up i'm
gonna go and get another another job
another side hustle we're gonna work
through this this is what i'm saying if
you're in a relationship
and you're got children together or
whatnot you're meant to be
doing that partnership anyway and that's
where the mindset should be at
but this is the thing that i think is
quite crazy because everyone talks about
oh i want love in a in a relationship i
want love in blah blah and the love that
they're talking about is a love that oh
he makes me he makes my insides you know
wiggle oh he does this he does that and
it's all about me
me me me when
if you're going to get married and have
a child
it should be a different sort of love
that you're thinking about it should be
the sort of love where it's like it's a
selfless love so
yes i'm not necessarily happy or i'm not
necessarily
in a situation that
i want to be in for the long term but
because i have a childish man and i
decided to bring a child into this world
they're the most important thing here
right now and so they're the thing i'm
focusing on it shouldn't be a situation
well i'm not happy he doesn't make
enough money so i'm going to leave now
you know that's it's just it's another
level of self-interest that would seem
um become far more prominent in this day
and age yeah but what will happen there
is that you'll have even more mental
health issues
in more sense
slavery or you're obligating people
to
but if you're deciding to have a child
to bring a child into this world you
need to consider that before one before
you have you know you just get married
and two before you have children of
course and then once you make that
decision it doesn't matter how you feel
i know but that's rational thinking
you're dealing with people that have
emotional impulses hypocrisy well i
guess personality disorders the question
are people happier today than they were
a hundred years ago when the divorce
rates were much lower
and like that's the thing i think a lot
of times people leave thinking they'll
be happier but you can't depend on
someone else to make you happy only you
can make you happy
and there are exceptions there are
exceptions with like domestic violence
and you know extreme cheating right no
way i think someone could make you happy
someone can make you happy yeah but
that's such a fickle feeling it's such a
fickle feeling it can change so easily
within yourself before you even get into
a relationship before you even have a
child
here's my thing yeah
you said women should be allowed to
decide what they do with their body
right in terms of when it comes to
pregnancy and you and you said as well
that um if the guy steps out too much
then that's the grounds for leaving him
yeah now i want to say to you if he gets
her pregnant the first time he steps out
are you going to leave him
what are the odds of that like come on
you're telling me the first time he
cheated he got it the first time you're
being reckless and like honestly that's
selfish too because you're putting
you're embarrassing your family would
you would you be in the relationship
would i would i leave the relationship
yeah if you had a kid with someone else
screw screw a random hoe one time
not i'll probably stay if i have a kid
but you made a whole ass child with the
random girl that you you have no control
over you no that means like you are
reckless you are reckless and it's
disrespectful it's so disrespectful it's
like come on like if if you have sex
with somebody outside of your marriage
yeah okay but
you you now made an investment from the
next 18 years and you have a marriage
over here like and condoms are 98
effective
condoms are 98 percent effective
and you're telling me you're telling me
that two percent time the first time you
hooked up with her it is
how many men have casual sex every like
we make it sound like two percent is not
a lot of people two percent of a lot of
people in england are a lot of people
but a lot of men do it wrong let's be
honest yeah a lot just don't like using
condoms
let's be honest like when when early on
when she asked you
your face changed it changed
man i i talk to guys all the time and
that like these guys be relying on pull
out with these crazy hoes and i'm like
and you're in a bad situation and i'm
like well
maybe you should have and i'm i'm all
for it's mostly on the woman if they get
pregnant but like you got to stop
trusting these girls like
they're not on birth control like they
say they are guys
look at why are you laughing because you
know it's true
maybe women should wear feminines in
school stuff
women should require the men they sleep
with wear condoms too i'm not i'm not
taking it off the woman but i'm saying
like at this point women have so much
power
right they have so much power they can
ruin your life with a kid yeah and they
can they can hold it over there's so
much power why would you give a crazy
girl that much power
it's just not smart it's not smart
because i was horny man like it and i
i'm just saying like as as a grown man
like no no wait no no no no no no no no
no no no no let's not get there
but the thing is it's true
even kevin even don't over talk me this
is my show um okay even kevin samuels
talked about that dick discipline yeah
he talks about that that's one of the
core values of a high value man
you have to have some dick discipline
kevin
promiscuous man
so
he died with on top of a woman that he
was she was she pregnant exactly was she
pregnant
you can you can go do your thing but be
smart yeah i get i get that but what i'm
saying to you accidents happen the man
only had one child and he was a 53 year
old man like not a problem no no no the
godfather is all right you know what i
mean like i'm not really saying it in
the sense of that but i'm saying in
terms of this black men we are not don't
bring don't say black
okay then why why don't all these guys
have kids exactly why don't why don't
all these men have because 98
50 of men in the u.s that are black are
single and child listen in the middle
class
98 so the 2 percent is going to be a
percentage of people but i'm saying to
you like we have no control over whether
or not kids say or not in terms of
you
you have no control over what there's
too many conflating issues going on here
no okay you have no after i've had do
you have control of whether you or not
you wear a condom yes okay do i have
control whether or not it bursts or not
no but most times
you sound like a woman right now because
you're you're arguing about the
exception rather than the rule no no no
no no no no no it's really no no you are
because you're you sound like this is
what girls do on my show they always
argue that the exception it's very
feminine uh paul two percent pearl's
gonna get you away well two percent is
not the exception
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait hold
on hold on in terms of the amount of
people so when we're talking about okay
if we said two percent of the world was
going to die tomorrow it's not an
insignificant amount of number so it's
not it's not like i get you when you say
the exception but women would do that in
terms of like the one-off person i'm
talking about two percent even the
one-off first could be five percent it's
still insignificant it's ninety-nine
percent let's say honestly let's say
let
this
this
i don't know it's not okay guys let me
just say this when you make an argument
it's best to make an argument
with the majority of the percentage with
the rule if you're going to make an
argument with the minority then you're
always going to look like you're trying
to make an excuse
rather than going with the general rule
you're talking about like two percent
right it's like when people talk about
grape and they talk about abortion okay
less than two percent of abortions are
because of grape right you can't argue
the two percent to say oh but what if
but what if bro you're arguing a two
percent argument any problem is the two
percent
argument as the two percent having the
problem if you get what i'm trying to
say we're talking about single
um we're talking about women that have
kids with men that don't want to have
them that's not necessarily a majority
of men so we're talking about that
it's not productive to the conversation
if you're always arguing the exception
two percent two no two percent is the
exception and you're not going to
convince me otherwise like it's not it's
not a good argument i agree with you
that two percent is the exception but
we're talking about the exception in
this case so no we're not this is my
this is my show we don't talk about the
exceptions we talk about the rule so do
you think the rule is that men are
single um that women are like
i think the rule is that women are more
in control if they get pregnant it's
their own damn fault and i say this all
the time but as a man if you're you have
kids left and right like when do you
learn from your behavior
like when like right i get that you know
and if it's a one time like one kid sure
but if you're having multiple different
baby mamas like that says something
about you and your lack of
responsibility like i'm i'm holding both
sexes accountable i get that if you're
what you were saying
okay the single single fathers or like
um
single parent households is not the
majority that's the exception
no it's like 50 percent
yes it is yes it is
single parent is not the majority we're
talking about the exception in this case
that's a huge that's a huge minority
that's interesting
to you that's not two percent is not a
huge minority
so it's not it's two percent it's not a
huge minority of anything
that like
in this room how many people are in this
room if you take two percent out of i
don't know the 10 people in this room it
might look big but if you if you take
two percent out of
a million what's that and just just on a
real note and just on a real note come
on most guys that have a lot of kids
aren't wearing condoms right most guys
that are that have a lot of kids aren't
wearing condoms let's just let's just be
real
yes let's just be real how many times
the condom going to split yeah come on
let's just like honestly be real
okay but
agree to disagree i'm just saying that
in terms of like there's a lot of
different reasons why
people are not in
a double
in a
normal relationship in terms of man
woman and kids and it's not necessarily
one reason there's a numerous amount of
reasons okay yes black people black
people there's a higher majority
please don't say black people because
statistically statistically black people
are more than likely in that single
parent household yeah because 72 percent
of single parent households exactly but
not 72 percent of all relationships so
i'm trying to say to you so i'm saying
to you as a majority of men black men
yeah that you would you say to your guy
all right you're probably having a
single parent household in the white
company in this white
counterpart he would be in a normal
relationship
more than likely that's from choice
what's your point because then why why
why wouldn't you just do what they're
doing
why would you just why would we just
take notes because we're dealing with
different problems both no so now
there's a reason why hold on there's a
reason why there's a reason why black
households are more than likely not
together and it and it's
and there's a lot to do with but why is
that not true for um african households
so like nigerians are gone
that's actually my point that's exactly
my point so i'm going to get to that now
so
wait oh no no no no no no no no no back
in the day
back in the days back in the days black
people were more than likely inside of a
wedding inside of a
marriage
pre-pre um
lynch okay can i ask you questions
do you think william whatever the black
community
experiences was worse now than enduring
slavery say that again do you think
whatever the black the black community
is experiencing was worse now than
during uh during slavery in terms of
what context bro every context
their lives it works
no you can't please please answer the
question yes or no was it worse
it was because i'll tell you why because
you're talking about a small
proportion of black people i'm asking a
specific question even within that
within that community you're going like
you're going everywhere right
okay okay okay do you think why why can
you ask questions
go through the same problems in terms of
like answer answer his question it's not
a good show if you're just going to keep
going off on youtube i need you to
answer his question do you think that
the black community okay
in america um specifically america that
their experience their lived experience
is worse now than it was during slavery
yes or no they live experiences yeah
they haven't lived no
no so why is it that back during slavery
black black families were married more
sorry um black men and black women are
married more than now i'll tell you why
bro there is an agenda there is an
agenda for black couples not to be
together and what there wasn't one then
back then hold on you were already
enslaved you didn't need to be separated
now that we've now that we've freed you
we have to enslave you in your mind how
we're going to enslave you in your mind
we need to separate your family unit so
basically just just blame hold on a
second in africa it's completely
different to the west
i was complete because in terms of
education but in terms of family
dynamics in terms of community in terms
of marriage in terms of religion in
terms of promiscuity in terms of what
you see on tv in terms of disney what
your child is um brought up by who
they're brought up by where they're left
in africa you're more than likely to be
staying in your great-grandmother's
house with your uncle there with your
auntie there with bubba there with with
your fault but aren't they living the
worse than people here it's more time
community looking aren't they living the
worse than people here more times so how
does that explain the fact that people
they're living like they're like they're
not exactly rich are they they're not
exactly you know they don't have the
benefits of living in the western world
and yet they're still staying together
so doesn't that just say that people
mean the people here there's a there's
an issue here yes
and again they were colonized so they
were like it's not as if they weren't
colonized well the white people weren't
there yet we're still not seeing the
same issues so what now
so wait a minute isn't there polygamy in
africa
in all of africa in all of africa in
christian africa no there isn't
christian africa yes nigeria the
influence of christianity is from where
from white people when they're staying
together so that doesn't make sense i
know about polygamy talking to the mic i
need you to talk about the mind so
polygamy is
is allowed in africa's certain african
countries right yes in certain cultures
yes don't have any polygamy here
yesterday not allowed it's illegal
obviously
yes we do like if you don't get married
you can have multiple multiple girls
marriage it's not marriage but marriage
is a you know a social construct right
isn't it's a social contract but you
have to sign certificates don't you have
to do a ceremony no you can get married
without a without a contract but
obviously it's just not but you won't be
seen by
consummation's marriage because that's
how you used to be in the bible so
consummation consummation was actual
marriage in the bible as in what having
sex
but again it doesn't what you're saying
doesn't debate what i'm saying i love it
because polygamy is not allowed what
does that have to do with condoms
i'll tell you why
i'll tell you why
i'm just being real with you like you
just have a bunch of excuses